you've got to ask yourself too if you
really want equality of outcome
maybe you want maximal difference
between people in some sense because
look
the only reason you can trade on your
ability as a comedian is because you're
actually better at it than other people
right right so you the only thing you
have to offer that's valid as a trade is
something that you're better at
so if if we insist that everyone has
exactly the same of everything well then
what do we have to offer each other
you know that yeah you know i don't
understand that and i don't understand
how that's commensurate with diversity
yeah that's interesting i've i've kind
of like built my career
based on that idea that
the comedy that was on tv wasn't the
funniest version
and i literally said well if i just put
my comedy on youtube
i think the average person will see that
there is more merit here
and they'll gravitate towards me right
and i think because these
institutions were so caught up in like
what you can and can't say and all this
other stuff and blah blah doesn't really
matter but
yet the the internet it does matter it
does matter exactly because you saw
i said in this book there's a chapter
right
notice that opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abdicated yes
well that's the story you just told you
said you noticed that
what was being meritorious wasn't being
rewarded yeah okay well that
sucks but it does open up an opportunity
for you if you have some merit
and then you can test it so you put your
comedy on youtube what happened
and then it blows up man and it was
crazy and it's like everything that i've
gotten from my career has come from the
fact that like the people were able to
decide it
you know it it it's it's quite
interesting like the disrupter that the
internet is because
around the same time that you were
exploding
i was starting to blow up and there's a
bunch of other figures and all of us
merit based in our own situations were
able to
to come to some sort of like you know
prominence obviously different levels
but
uh because the people decided we should
be there
like that's what the internet does you
see it happening i have a friend of ours
named benuet is really smart guy but
he's like that's all the internet is
it's the ultimate disruptor and it will
happen to every institution wall
street's going through it now
with the whole gamestop thing they're
just finding ways to disrupt the people
will band together
and they will disrupt and there's a tool
for the disruption
and it's really cool at least for i
guess guys like you
and your contemporaries myself and my
contemporaries because we got a [ __ ]
chance to fight
you know we had to ask for permission
before hey can you put me on tv
what can i say i'll try to figure out
the best way to say it around you know
what you guys
i think is cool and then when we just
did it based on our own accord we put
out the best version of it and then got
the most success
it's very very rewarding it is very
rewarding and it's just really cool to
see this happen all at the same time
yeah yeah well it it's it's it's well
it's a consequence of this immense
technological revolution isn't it
we've got this insane power now all of
us are tv producers all of us are movie
producers all of us are radio
broadcasters it's right there at your
fingertips
yeah and that's such a revolutionary
change from
three decades ago that it's it's it's
almost unimaginable
and not only do we have all that
bandwidth and that communication
capacity but it's also permanent
sword you know because television
stations back in the nineteen sixties
you broadcast something
when it was gone gone gone gone
now this now videos have the same
permanence as books
it's so stunning and you know people say
you know i was talking to russell brand
the other day and
i like russell and he's very very smart
yes stunningly smart at times
and he said you know he was talking
about people not having a voice and i
thought
who wait you have a voice now if you
want to know you you
and you can talk to as many people as
will listen to you yeah
that's a voice it's like can you do
anything with that well perhaps not but
perhaps you can too
not only not only is there a voice
there's an algorithm
that will amplify interest meaning
if people enjoy what you're saying
science will push it out to more people
so it's it is wow it's like it's
merit on crack you know it's merit on
steroids
you could be saying the most interesting
thing on a soapbox in new york and maybe
10 or 15 people hear about it and then
they never hear about it again
but the fact that youtube or these
different platforms are
incentivized to share your [ __ ] that
people like
never a better time never a better time
to have some merit
you